welcome back it's time for our mornings
with metro segment today we're joined
live by assistant sheriff andrew walsh
thanks again for being here thanks for
having us nice to see you well because
of cobin 19 you know a lot of programs
around the county uh were put on hold or
either shut down but uh talk about the
the program that the clark county
detention center is bringing back it's
an event called dsd cares yeah so the
the folks at the clark county detention
center that work for metro do a great
job of uh you know with the people that
when they're uh are leaving the goal is
that they don't ever have to come back
so
but many times we've learned over the
years that when people are leaving they
don't have identification they don't
have a doctor's appointment they don't
have a place to live they don't have
family they don't have a support system
once they exit the clark county
detention center so
with the goal of keeping them
out of the detention center and getting
them re-enfranchised into the community
we bring in every service provider that
you can think of that can help
check all those boxes so that when they
leave they have the ability to go out
and go and start a normal life
and not come back to the detention
center reoffending is you know something
is the goal we don't want them to
reoffend so
the key thing would be for us is that
you know as long as we are allowed uh
and can with the covert restrictions uh
continue to bring people into the
facility because uh the jail is one of
those places too where we we have to
make sure we're controlling the
population in there who gets to come in
who doesn't we don't want the inmates to
get sick while they're there so
it's difficult to do when
we have restrictions but
as the restrictions were eased we were
able to at least do one event and
hopefully we can we can do more as we go
through this
uh rise and fall of the covid numbers
well next week there's a new community
uh information hub that's opening at
resorts world and what was the what was
the plan behind this how did that
project come about resort world is a
great thing for our community you know
it's a it's a great thing for the north
end of the strip and as we see the
development going on in that area you
know the the sheriff and the
owners of resort world came together and
were able to partner on putting a
community hub there for people so
you know tourists when they come to town
if we've learned anything over the years
they don't know where the local police
stations are and technology has made it
a little bit easier for them but it's
also a place where you know metro now
has a forward-facing uh
small footprint on las vegas boulevard
and that north end of the strip is you
know really vital uh as it can become a
vital
part of the the community so you know i
think it'll be good for people to see
that there's a place to if they need to
speak to a police officer or or get some
information get directions uh
really we are thankful to resort world
for being able to uh partner with them
to do that because
all right thank you so much assistant
sheriff andrew walsh great to have you
on we always love hearing firsthand from
metro thanks for having me thank you if
you have a question for metro police you
can submit it on our website
eightnewsnow.com find out if your
question was answered every wednesday
during mornings with metro